So let's talk about Rogers for a minute.
He was a devout fundamentalist Protestant.
And I think that's important to know
because a lot of his thinking has a very
strong Protestant flavor.
I mean,
the reason I concentrate on such things
and the philosophical background,
if these thinkers,
because you have to understand the axioms,
the safer that you're dealing with dirt,
you actually don't understand them at all.
And when you're assessing the
axiomatic presuppositions of the paper,
you're usually outside the
thinkers thought in some sense,
right?
Because you're looking at axioms,
but you don't get it unless you,
unless you know the accident.
And so Carl Rogers thought was
deeply grounded in his Protestantism,
but it's,
his father in particular was a scientific
farmer and applied the scientific
method on the farm that he grew up in.
And so Rogers had a devout fundamentalist
background of the sort that was more
typical in the thirties and the
forties but he also had us powerful,
uh,
understanding of the scientific method
and practical observations of its
utility.
So
he,
his first academic training was at the
Union theological seminary seminary.
In the mission of,
of that seminary was to evangelize
the world in their generation.
If I remember correctly,
was when he was on a boat to China to
serve as a missionary that he first
started to question the
absolute reality of his,
of his Protestant beliefs.
It isn't that he abandoned particularly,
it's that he incorporated them into a
approach to psychotherapy that fulfilled
all the preconditions for this.
There's a,
there's this striving towards a kind of
interpersonal perfection that goes along
with Protestantism.
There's an idea that the most important
realization of the most fundamental
reality is to be had in direct and
honest communication between two people
and
two or more people.
That's a place where you might say,
if you're thinking about it symbolically,
that the living word emerges
and Roger's thinking is deeply,
deeply rooted in that kind of conception.
And it's,
it's partly that he believed that if
you could integrate yourself properly,
if you could put yourself together in
some sense at every level of analysis,
then you'd be able to exist,
communicate in a way that was,
there's a Ph Eddie,
and for to this that was
optimally beneficial to you,
but also optimally beneficial to
other people at the same time.
And a lot of that would emerge in
your interactions with each other in
communication.